são gotardo a todas e todos
neste evento magnífico espírito o
partido comemora mil do havia uma
ditadura em portugal
quando eu era miúdo havia violações de
privacidade com política do estado
tantos anos depois em 7 que nesta sala
muita gente nessa altura não era nem
vazamento
nascida em que situação é que estamos
houve uma alteração radical diminuição
das restrições constituição democrática
que aliás consagra um lugar destacado
várias liberdades incluindo a proteção
contrato passa a e o mundo totalmente
diferente designadamente o mundo marcado
pelas tecnologias pela era digital o que
é realmente impressionante é que muita
gente diz era digital logo renunciamos a
esperança de termos privacidade é uma
coisa típica de um quadro tecnológico e
de conhecimento em que os maiôs
tecnológicos que não permitiam receber
tudo o que hoje é seu nível sobre cada
um nós hoje é que esse evangelho não é
que o meu não é em que o comendo e a 1
com o mato com máxima felicidade
possível designadamente cento das
pessoas que tão má como outras
enfermeiras é epidemia da devassa
sistemática em incontrolável e
propiciada pela inocência em cultura e
de prevenção a cada um dos cidadãos
destaca don hahn há quem diga em árvore
por exemplo eram aplicados que agora
quando a tecnologia e como os kits
eletronics espécie de mini mini 9 anos
será possível a certa altura obter a
quantidade de lojas ç e determinar o
estado de seu uso é do dotal evangelista
magalhães ao cair não é que o como
instrumento as noites mas é um movimento
cumpriu e esfrego é nos comunicado pela
ciência mas as mais das vezes não é
comunicada pela ciência
estamos não conta
isso em que desabaram todos os temas
tradicionais de governação em que os
estados nacionais perderam sua função o
ver na limitada e diminuída em que o
principal vento que sopra é o da agulha
do gol da globalização e temos no
oriente o centro de gravidade da
economia mundial
os sistemas tradicionais funcionam mal
em toda a parte
ana que o continente é que nós estamos
também essas mudanças condicionou muito
a forma de resolver esta epidemia que é
perda de privacidade
e quem esquece isso fica muito frustrado
por não encontrar soluções fáceis não
encontra porque não há como explicar
porque a crise de autoridade existe
dificulta é cristo cultura digital
também a governante não tem mais vaga aí
que acham que o tema estamos a tratar
aqui é uma patentes absoluta
não faz sentido fazer na base de dados
dos toffees outra coisa assim
abertamente sexy quiser dividir atenções
do corpo docente
mas a verdade é que estamos num quadro
em que a desconfiança se agravam a
possibilidade dos outros problemas e
alguns diminuem
ontem mesmo estava ver esse recorte que
mandaram a dos estados unidos que
anuncia uma coisa boa está a anunciar
neste momento a comissão européia que
dirige as nossas relações comerciais
externas neste ponto desde 2009 tem um
pouco disso ninguém notou mais lembrada
é talvez chegou o corpo para os serranos
pelo peugeot empresas européias terem a
possibilidade de aplicar o pai vá se f
de 74 norte americanos têm de 74 com
paga se r protege contra certas devassa
da vida privada e que foi adaptado à era
digital
os europeus não tem essa pretensão dos
estados unidos o benfica que somos
cidadãos em diante a relação a violações
pelo estado do médico talvez tenhamos
isso e aquilo que estava nos sustentar
neste minuto é isso que está a
privacidade é alguma coisa que nós
podemos defender temos que aprender como
a limitações à privacidade perfeitamente
justificados aquelas que existiam antes
em relação ao combate ao crime por
exemplo que não merece o v6 de proteção
a intenção múltiplas vem várias fontes
nasceu ciliar na função única na bala de
prata é capaz de resolver tudo ea maior
parte das vezes que falamos de
privacidade não sabemos que estamos a
falar pro misturando as coisas
diferentes e logo a conversa é uma
conversa confusa
o primeiro aspecto que eu gostava de
sublinhar quando em 95 escrever
portanto prático da internet enfim que
tentou ser um pequeno evangelho
divulgação da matéria quando ela era uma
espécie de monopólio de pessoas da vossa
escola das escolas deste carlos
confessou gato martins um dos pioneiros
o quadro totalmente diferente do atual
hoje o quadro é este há uma mudança
radical do contexto digital
a banda larga à internet das coisas
aproximar se a novos equipamentos e
novos instrumentos
a voz do técnico nós telemóvel título
gratuito a aplicações explodirem
e vem aí outras novidades serão elas
próprias mudanças no contexto da eta com
tudo o que significa capacidade da
atenção do tendências epidemias olhe por
exemplo mas também o trânsito opções
decisões situações concretas e também o
conhecimento em casas inteligentes de
dados em transportes no nosso próprio
corpo pode transmitir uma massa
formidável dados que é transmitida
produtos
o problema é que qualquer para uma
central que os analisa e dispara avisos
magalhães por uribe double nata cuidado
não comer não comer não comer tudo isso
é hoje perfeitamente possível está até
caminho e cidades inteligentes com os
seus avisos no microblog e popular a um
choque tanto cuidado com isto porque o
outro isso é positivo mas traz problemas
cláudio campeão a evolução para claudia
ela própria e exige um pacote específico
de medidas de defesa da privacidade e de
controle daquilo que nós comunicamos a
nuvem pode estar embaixo do chão é e
o revela muito sobre nós e pode revelar
aliás tudo
outro aspecto quando nós perguntamos o
que nos devem estar nesse novo contexto
tão mudado os peritos respondentes como
está aí em quinto lugar e não em
primeiro em quinto lugar os malfadados o
e amaldiçoados é caro de todos os tipos
uns autores de black jackers x merss e
toda essa turma malta deve ser tratada e
combatida coisas sobre nós o que comprou
nos últimos tempos através de forma
pegou cumpriu ou não as obrigações de
pagar apropriadamente que o comprou
forma parcelada
outro uso ação governamental permitem
gerenciar o problema é que eu de aprovar
legislação que permite por exemplo a
colocação em sistema de informação da
informação é pessoal em largas grossas
para apurar se houver esquinas em causa
com o controle do minuto e em condições
que pensam que são dados não podem
avaliar o trabalho ninguém notou
especialmente no problema de fundo por
outro lado as coisas relacionadas com os
nossos amigos que podem sem querer
transmitir ao senhor informação que nós
não temos e transmitindo quero mais
saber que tenho no ano da festa do
avante da falta o do luís amor de deus
alguém pode o quê quando falta é
incrível como fosse capaz e bocas e
nessa semana gasta e por último nós
próprios somos o próprio supremo que
tinham pela pelo faz pouco é que
respondem a mensagens do messenger é que
os depois fui citado a receber em 19
milhões em contratos por outro lado a nu
uma fortuna perdida na nigéria e que
querem que nós levamos esses 9 milhões
amanhã
o ensaio nesta manhã ice ice não é que o
rafa roubar avaí
ok tudo isso existe tudo isso pode vir
conosco nós realmente somos nós o
principal
quem diz isso os tipos de répteis em
tóquio como irene nos oferecem esse
serviço
a pretensão da nossa reputação contra o
baath adequada
portanto existe paz preso e subitamente
estávamos tranquilamento quando um
soldado que desertou soldado manning o
chelsea nani e um contra tanto mama
entidade contratada que vivia no hawai e
acesso à informação sensível nos
vendaram o durável mundo da national
security agency
contudo o que as tecnologias os planetas
na interseção de fácil tratamento
tratamento em massa tradução em massa
voz do técnico quiserem através dos mais
sofisticados e isso mudou o contexto em
que nós discutimos essas questões
infelizmente não há uma solução mágica
não há uma praia celam uma espécie de
godzilla que nos protege de todos pretos
e que ataca quando os atacantes querem
obter informação não há embora haja uma
organização chamada pra você lá da porta
bom e há também uma série de ferramentas
que nos podem permitir conseguir obter
informação ou protegê la de forma
adequada bom quanto o nosso problema o
problema é que as novidades digitais
podem e as novidades proteção vem até
nós em sobral chan numa sociedade que
parece sendo atrasada defasada em
relação ao ideal
ainda ontem electronic frontier
foundation fez aquilo que eu acho que
deve ser feito em portugal e galiza
papel seja feita pela equipa ou pelas
equipas científicas aqui da estrada nova
que é o ranking das entidades principais
do mundo da web ferramenta web português
que existe em função do amor e do
respeito que tem a privacidade ou contra
a ganância devassa que exibam por uma
extrema porque futebol é de fato obriga
à constituição que a obra da legislação
é ela própria em certificados não só um
lugar como técnico no lugar porque essa
força do sinal civil pode ajudar as
instituições de renome do parlamento o
governo e da própria comissão atenção
dados intervir alertando para situações
inaceitáveis
por exemplo nos no no ranking da
electronic frontier foundation
nós descobrimos aqui alguém quer
intervir
nós descobrimos que o arquiteto proteste
insuficientemente os seus clientes e
portanto quem usa ou até para 7 tem ou
teve dados confidenciais third idéia é
porque uma máquina idéia em geral e em
particular mas isso vai gerar uma guerra
de empresas entre os amantes da
privacidade e que são um pouco relaxadas
ou muito em relação à privacidade do
tempo que no último grande missa solene
da apple tratou de tranqüilizar apple
como uma empresa amante da privacidade
explicar como resolver o problema das
ruas com efe e com o governo norte
americano por e simplesmente deixa de
ver uma chave dos geral parece de os
materiais da época a apple não tem essa
chave só entidade que tem o seu iphone
ou o que quer que seja da apple pode
facultar o acesso á aquilo que está no
seu computador e é tudo cifrado e o nome
do jogo é cifra encriptar purificar não
permitir o acesso indiscriminado
tudo tremeu esta guerra e vamos ter uma
guerra por políticas públicas
isto é abordar os principais temas não
interessa nada e verá os que dizem é o
meu caso est me interessa interessa
muito ter celular deve ser produzido e
as pessoas têm que ter não apenas
educação para a privacidade mas lei que
proteja a privacidade e temos várias
mãos mas agora com isso e temos que
saber ou nós não temos açúcar branco
andré porque eu sou frequentador horas
as mais diversas
nesta manhã
fez vários possantes básico de todo o
planeta em filmes como entende
naturalmente mas nunca barrolândia eu
estou sujeito é que o ray o autocrata um
bigode tem paciência - este possa que
não têm lugar não possui ainda quatro
obsceno sendo apropriados presumido não
faço e não marcou porque não faz
qualquer muito em casa tá fora altar
bloqueado até logo
sem explicações não custa nada e
portanto no futuro nós vamos ter mais
dados privados nas mãos de um fio zor
sul é não chamar agora ao tocar mas é o
nome alterar a política de privacidade
no mês de janeiro entrou em vigor e está
entrada em vigor por praga de tensão que
não quiser usar não usa
mas se usar perde a socar barrolândia os
jogos com taxi to phone é grátis e
videoconferência grátis a mensagem
gráficas instantânea as fotografias
grátis o depósito grátis tudo que é
grátis
entrou naturalmente saber tudo que eu
faço o tratamento justo o contrário numa
altura em que estava a fazer um negócio
difícil espalhava pistas totalmente
falsas não faz pouco está dizia que
estava num sítio estava no outro entrava
um tipo de coisa se estava a consumir
outras e própria construir a minha festa
à fantasia rosa e não condicionada mal o
rap e me aconteceu
portanto devemos prestar atenção isto é
unir os associados função curiosa de
portugal há poucas associações de
internautas eu tentei fundar uma em
95/96 sem grande êxito a aps
às vezes a pensão dos filhos da
informação alguns tantas outras
realmente nenhuma particulamente reunida
na defesa destes direto sem nenhuma
privacidade concreta é a culpa também
porventura mas é verdade que o tema é um
tema que será cada vez mais importante a
atenção por exemplo quebra no reino
unido e repetente tem como um dos
objetivos fundamentais proibir a
criptografia primeira paragem de
correspondência corrente e isso no
entanto é justamente essencial para a
defesa da segurança e da privacidade
como provar
notórios os estados unidos sempre
publicados sublinham isso mesmo
e se a gente olhar para o que o cuca eu
e isto é um artigo sobre nudez privacy
privacidade há evoluções pagas
comerciais
nesse caso com uma mulher aqui tudo a
atenção das pessoas tendem a ser mais
mobilizada pelos fly do baixo pela parte
de baixo do suai do pela parte de cima o
que um tipo filmou um ato sexual com uma
prostituta que continuem constitucional
é proibido autorizado ver com a
intimidade da vida privada da prestadora
do serviço ou não e como é que eu fiz
aqui o tecnológico momento em que o
computador em cima da mesa da cama em
cima tinha uma câmera ganhou na cabeça
curioso giro e entretanto não discutimos
o essencial
o essencial é que atenas precisa da
atração - 10 por exemplo é esta senhora
se botar seja feliz
a manipulação de uma pessoa cidade
grande
a carla bruni ao caia vai aos terminais
defende ela que ganhou um milhão de
euros voaram a sua nudez e depois foram
apanhados olha é vida é tão famosas e
também estão duas responsabilidades
tenderá a ser efetivada a manipulações
violador ps após preto pode botar estudo
e até se pode verificar que esta feira
está dotada de um espaço no interior das
suas pernas
as escadas tão mal alinhada não saíram
para tomar uma goleada mas isto é
totalmente indiferente não nota b prova
não é isso que é grave e vai finalmente
teremos também disto mais crimes mais
cometidos neste domínio o que nós temos
que ter
temos que ter aí uma defesa contra este
crime e que somos nós a regra número um
que pode impedir essa ter essa certeza
tendo cultura
protegemos entre tantas mais quem
estamos a cnpd quando existe os
tribunais
associamos e nunca acertando o evangelho
que diz
meus filhos não signatários para os três
usaram o facebook termo de uso
de lugar por completo porque essa regra
do jogo é essa não é a regra do jogo e
tivemos um disco de jazz e muito
obrigado